SpaceX is celebrating its historic
launch of the world's most powerful
rocket did you see this the Falcon Heavy
lasted off yesterday on its first
attempt carrying a cherry red Tesla
convertible into orbit
two of its boosters and landed back down
on earth SpaceX CEO Elon Musk that was
his own personal car said he was proud
and in disbelief after the very
successful launch Manuel Bojorquez is at
Kennedy Space Center in Florida with
this story man well good morning a good
morning the Falcon Heavy lifted off from
the same launch pad right back there
that was once used to send astronauts to
the moon an exciting day for thousands
of spectators here that clearly
surpassed all expectations including
those of SpaceX CEO Elon Musk
the Falcon Heavy's 27 engines lifted the
rocket off the same launch pad used by
Apollo 11 the successful launch of the
world's most powerful rocket was
received with jubilation among SpaceX
employees but CEO Elon Musk described a
different kind of relief I had this
image of just a giant explosion on the
pad with a wheel bouncing down the road
like has a logo landing somewhere
the launch was a near-perfect display of
the type of capabilities SpaceX is known
for Falcon heavies three rocket boosters
detached and just over eight minutes
after launch two of them safely landed
back on earth touching down side by side
finally the big reveal Musk's very own
Tesla Roadster with a dummy called star
man at the wheel against the all
inspiring backdrops of planet Earth
the music of David Bowie's life on Mars
playing on a loop that's probably most
exciting I've ever seen
musk says the next stop for star man and
his roadster is a trip through the
asteroid belt and in case they should
stumble upon any one must print it a
message on the car circuit board that
reads made on earth by humans I mean
it's kind of silly and fun you know
silly fun things are important just
gonna be out there in deep space for
maybe millions of billions of years
maybe just covered by some future alien
race thinking what the heck what were
these guys doing did they worship this
car the only mishap yesterday was the
rocket center booster crashing into the
Atlantic instead of landing on a barge
the Falcon Heavy costs half a billion
dollars to develop but at ninety million
dollars per flight musk says it's
cheaper than the competition though he
still has to prove it's reliable Nora
reliable indeed that's right men well
thank you